este que tenemos aquí es un sólido
revolución cuyo volumen pudimos calcular
en un vídeo previo usando el método de
discos en aquel vídeo integramos con
respecto a y para obtener el volumen lo
que vamos a hacer ahora es obtener el
mismo volumen integrando con respecto a
x para lo cual usaremos el método de
cascarones lo que vamos a hacer es que
esta región que está comprendida entre
la curva que iguala x cuadra de la curva
igual a raíz de x la vamos a rotar
alrededor de la recta vertical x
igualados y haremos esto y haremos esto
para la región donde ya igual a raíz de
x es mayor que ye igual a x cuadrada
esto es entre x igual a 0 y x igual a 1
hagámoslo usando el método de cascarones
y para esto vamos a construir un
cascarón vamos a hacerlo aquí déjame
hacerlo en un color distinto
vamos a construir aquí un cascarón
imaginemos que aquí tenemos este
rectángulo cuyo ancho es de equis y cuya
altura es la diferencia entre estas dos
curvas aquí lo tendremos aquí tenemos
ese cascarón que estamos dibujando aquí
lo tenemos del otro lado y es un
cascarón es como un cilindro muy muy muy
delgado aquí lo tenemos por la parte del
frente por aquí vendría la parte de
atrás y tienen cierto espesor este está
dado por de x de x sería el espesor de
este cascarón vamos a sombrear lo para
que podamos apreciar mejor la
profundidad de este cascarón así que
cuando giras este rectángulo alrededor
de la recta x igual a 2 obtienes un
cascarón como éste veamos entonces cómo
calcular este volumen es un problema al
cual ya nos hemos enfrentado antes
necesitamos calcular cuál sería el área
de la parte superior del cascarón cuál
sería el área de esta circunferencia
sabe
para calcular el área de una
circunferencia necesitamos conocer el
radio de la circunferencia esta
distancia que tenemos aquí esta
distancia de aquí entonces va a ser la
distancia horizontal entre el eje x
igualados y el valor de x que tengamos
aquí cualquiera que éste sea esto de
aquí es entonces la distancia entre 2 y
x es decir el radio de esta
circunferencia es igual a 2 - x de tal
manera entonces que la circunferencia va
a ser igual a 2 x pi por el radio 2 pi
por 2 - x
ahora bien el área superficial de la
parte externa de este cascarón está va a
ser igual a la circunferencia que es
igual a 2 pi por 2 - x por la altura de
este cascarón y cuál va a ser la altura
bueno la altura va a ser la diferencia
de estas dos curvas como función de x es
decir la curva superior que es igual a
raíz de x menos la curva inferior que es
igual a x cuadrada va a ser entonces
raíz cuadrada de x menos x
vamos a ponerlo por acá voy a hacerlo
amarillo aquí tenemos entonces raíz
cuadrada de x menos equis cuadrada
entonces si queremos el volumen de este
cascarón que tenemos aquí voy a ponerlo
acá abajo
voy a hacerlo en blanco va a ser igual a
2 pi por 2 - x por raíz de x menos equis
cuadrada esto que acabamos de calcular
aquí es el área el área superficial de
este cascarón el área externa social de
este cascarón y para obtener volumen
tenemos que multiplicarlo por el espesor
del cascarón y el espesor del cascarón
es de equis y si queremos todo este
volumen tenemos que sumar todos los
cascarones que tenemos aquí y tomar el
límite a medida que de x se hace más
pequeño y aumenta el número de
cascarones y entonces cuál es nuestro
intervalo las x van a ir desde 0 a 1
nuestro intervalo integración es de 0 a
1 y esto nos va a dar el volumen de esta
figura de este sólido de revolución que
tenemos aquí